leonard fournette
out of work for very long he cleared
waivers after being released on monday
by the jaguars no one wanted him until
he became a free agent there was some
buzz yesterday that the patriots were
interested more on that in a second
once that got out though in come
the tampa bay buccaneers and leonard
fournette quickly signs on
to become
a bruising between the tackles
complement to ronald jones and i don't
know what's going to happen with sean
mccoy i'm told that he's been told he's
not going anywhere i'll believe it when
i see it but leonard fournette staying
close to home
and joining tom brady mike evans rob
gronkowski had 1152 rushing yards last
year chris you know i
i i i'm intrigued to say the least by
what he's going to do for the buccaneers
no i mean you know this is to me this is
a steal you know that i i value the
player at a very high level now
you know is he a headache off the field
yeah the more that we've sat here and
and separated ourselves from this you
know the jaguars in the story yeah the
more i've heard that he's maybe a little
bit more of a headache than i gave him
credit for in jacksonville but uh i
still think he's too talented as we see
for teams to turn down and of course a
guy like bruce arians with the tom brady
at quarterback if he's concerned about
oh this guy's a pain in the butt or
whatever else i think he probably looks
at it and goes i think i got a pretty
good culture here right now to where you
know i'm not saying it's new england but
i think people are going to come in
they're going to buy in they're going to
see what brady's doing gronk's there
there's a lot of good leadership and
then you talk about football
i mean yeah compliment to ronald jones
sledgehammer runner but man you know
mike that's where i look at it and go
he's got more big playability than a
ronald jones or anybody else on that
roster i would be shocked if he's not
the go-to guy and to me where it's
really great for the bucks is that
they'll take pressure off the aryans
brady pass game early in the season a
little bit to where it just won't have
to hey you know we don't have to worry
about tom having to drop back and throw
it 35 times every game as we get the o
line fixed and all that now they're
going to have a true viable threat
that's going to scare people in the run
game and i think it takes the pressure
off the pass game and evans and
everything like that and of course it'll
make them more balanced and a little
more effective especially early in the
year when they're trying to get their
feet underneath them
what do you make of the fact that the
analytics crowd isn't a big fan of
leonard fournette well yeah i i get that
but you know the analytics crowd okay so
where was the defense supposed to go
in leonard fournette's rookie year
because people are mad at him because it
was 3.9 yards per carry listen blake
bortles couldn't throw the ball seven
feet so nobody played past defense
against jacksonville everybody's gotta
like it's a team sport so everybody if
you went back and watched film from that
year you'd go
whoa that mean there's nine guys within
like you know eight yards of the line of
scrimmage everybody was ready for
leonard fournette in the run game i mean
when you played jacksonville back then
it was don't let them run the clock out
don't let fournette beat you and then
don't turn the ball over and let jalen
ramsey and yannick and gawkway and
kaleis campbell score defensive
touchdowns same thing last year it's not
a whole lot different quarterback issues
they couldn't really get it going teams
knew
okay leonard fournette in the run game
that's what the jacksonville jaguars are
going to establish and also
jacksonville still in the process of
trying to figure out their offensive
line right now so what makes people
think that it just was like wide open
holes and he was messing up you know i
even saw somebody challenge me the other
day and went you know well miles sanders
breaks more tackles than leonard
fournette and i go okay yeah maybe the
statistics show that they wouldn't if it
was apples for apples two guys in the
hole and one of them have to go against
each other but so many runs of leonard
fournette get to the line of scrimmage
and there's nowhere to go so he's like
almost in place like where do i go
there's no hole there's nothing and then
the first guy that tackles him he's kind
of stuck in a mosh pit and he goes down
and as compared to mile sanders who got
to run behind a really good offensive
line and had a big big holes to go
through there was more room to make
people miss more room to make that
defender get on their heels a little bit
to then where maybe he could run him
over so analytics there's so much more
context to it all the time and i think
you'll see his worth a little bit more
here with the offense that we'll be able
to take some of the stress off of him
and you're gonna have to worry about
other things in that passing game in
brady and so on
i explained that okay how was that i
think you did analytics has its place
but we ultimately have to acknowledge
that football is a different kind of
animal when you you start to play and
it's 11 on 11 and how one guy does is so
dependent on what the other 10 do or
fail to do
and and like you said if there isn't a
passing threat it makes it harder to run
because the scheme is going to be
designed to take away the guy who had
1152 rushing yards last year
76 catches for 522 yards on top of it
over 1600 yards from scrimmage the
quietest 1 600 yards from scrimmage
one had last year more rushing yards
than joe mixon dalvin cook aaron jones
and josh jacobs and and and yeah he
sucks for some reason i don't understand
some i don't get it so
we'll see what he does with the tampa
bay buccaneers but chris i want to go
back
to how this all came together yesterday
yeah because when i saw the report that
the patriots are interested
right i had
my my my initial reaction was no they're
not because if they were you wouldn't
know about it until they sign him right
and in the event that they were
interested the key conjugation is were
because they tell agents all the time
if any of this gets out
we're out yes
the patriots unlike any other team have
mastered the ability of getting everyone
afraid of what they will do if you run
your mouth you don't run your mouth
right period right so i personally
believe and go ahead and and flash the
conspiracy theory message at the bottom
of the screen i believe that fournette's
camp strategically leaked it to somebody
who covers the patriots to get the
buccaneers or someone else interested
and we said this with cam newton if
anyone had any idea that bill belichick
was interested in cam newton cam newton
would have been gone before bill
belichick had a chance to sign him and i
think that's what happened yesterday
someone put out the false idea that the
patriots were interested in fournette
and it woke the buccaneers up and
mission accomplished and that's how the
sausage gets made sometimes folks yeah
and i think that's how it got made
yesterday yeah i might i don't doubt it
uh you know first off you're spot on if
if an agent player leaks that oh i might
be signing with the patriots or i'm in
new england visiting them right now the
the patriots will cut the cord
immediately and move on because they'll
know that to them that's like oh we
can't trust you you can't get in the
trust right here because who knows who
you're going to tell and what you're
going to say once you get here on the
team and you're going to release
information that way yeah they don't
want anybody ever knowing that's the way
they run their organization and you're
right they've they've done a good job of
scaring people within their organization
or anybody that wants to do business
with their organization from talking uh
and they're masters at that
and then i'm i'm kind of with you mike
you know the other
dot to connect here is jason light the
gm of the tampa bay buccaneers he came
from new england too and it just makes
me wonder if like you know leonard
fournette's agent and his camp realized
like hey
you know
tampa kind of likes our guy but i need
to get you know they might need a little
nudge over the edge to make this happen
maybe i float that new england rumor and
jason light who came from new england's
gonna be like oh i'm not gonna let those
guys get him you know and that amps up
his intensity or fire or whatever to
sign him i i thought kind of the same
things mike when it went down and i have
uh i have a hard time thinking that new
england was legitimately interested too
with the fact that it came out publicly
and when jason light gets a phone call
from a guy who played quarterback for 20
years in new england that we better get
this guy that creates a greater sense of
urgency as well and i think that look
and i'm i'm being complimentary of
whoever from fournette's camp recognized
this is the way to light the fuse right
because it worked right right it worked
and it worked to perfection and now he's
got a deal to play for one year with
tampa bay buccaneers and we'll see where
it goes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports